what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you have to decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in and the
foreseeable future
oh man I was listening to forget-me-nots
by saint-germain you know I love that
song it's got this really cool jazzy
hip-hop vibe to it and it just sounds
amazing like Shane Jermaine make some
really really good music I want to say
it's from the album of tourists I'm not
going to sort it out there but it's one
of the coolest songs that you're ever
going to hear which by the way a guy
actually put together a Spotify playlist
of all the songs I've ever used and I
have it on my Twitter account you could
probably at comix explain it's on there
somewhere kind of love where but I've
been posting with them last day or so so
it should be relatively easy to find
anyway so so groups versus the Hulk all
right here's the deal
this is 1976 right this is Hulk annual
number 5 written by Lynn wine and Chris
Claremont so it's 1976 comes guys this
was the era of comic books really before
Peter David took over and The Incredible
Hulk was just kind of free-floating
from one villain to the next and so it
was just kind of you'd see these stories
crop up and the hope would just like
accidentally stumble into some place you
should be and it would lead to him
fighting against you know humans which
in turn would lead to the arrival of
superheroes and the Hulk would fighting
in superheroes and then he would just
say you know if I had enough and he
would leave and the story would be over
that was pretty much the Incredible Hulk
from like the 1960s to the 1980s you
know really when when like bill Mantlo
have to get let's take over and when
Peter David took over so um again it was
kind of one of these things where it was
just sort of just free-floating stories
but great the way you think of him is
not the way he originally appeared in
Marvel Comics his first appearance came
in pills to astonish number 13 in 1960
and he was a Stanley Jack Kirby creation
so again it's kind of cool to see but he
predates like the Fantastic Four and he
predates spider-man and those guys but
it was kind of one of these things right
in like the early days of Marvel Comics
Stan Lee and Jack Kirby were just like
writing stuff and sending it out really
making stuff Jack Kirby was the one
drawing it but they were just making
stuff and sending it out and that was
that was the pattern it was just like
make it send it make it said to make it
send it then it was good because it gave
us things like the x-men fantastic for
spider-man back to the environment so on
and so forth but then we had things like
group problems and the way he originally
appeared he was just like this thing
just like this giant you know for
colosseo really was just like a monster
of con from Planet X I mean they
didn't really give him the name it was
just like the monster from Planet X and
so the result was that he was just this
guy who showed up on earth for the
purpose of just like capturing humans of
an experimenting like studying them and
that was really it but the way it was
done was kind of weird because 1960s
comics was a little strange and what
ended up happening is some guy named
Leslie Evans basically ran to the cops
and hey look there's this giant tree
monster that's terrorizing the town the
cops said whatever man you know get off
your drugs you're a crazy person
so Leslie Leslie Allen came he came back
he developed like these artificial
termites they basically ate Groot and
that was the end of him like that was
basically it was a pretty gruesome way
for him to go out but what ended up
happening is there were a series of
stories or least there was a series of
stories involving a guy named Ben knew I
think it's how you pronounce it it's Xen
and you and this guy was basically just
a dude from another dimension and again
that's where a lot of those stories
hailed from it was kooky locations
beings that just kind of popped up out
of nowhere and and ultimately then kind
of had a couple campaigns but one of the
most notable was going against the
defenders which at the time was Doctor
Strange Namor Silver Surfer and the
Incredible Hulk and again it was just
Marvel's attempt to kind of bolster the
roster of the defenders nobody really
bought into it because it has kind of
seemed like a poor man's Avengers but
the fact remains here that one of the
most notable heroes is in who had gone
against was the Incredible Hulk and so
resumable constantly been bandaged from
the planet Earth what ended up happening
is he basically made his arrival once
more and was just plotting world
domination underground but the
Incredible Hulk in this particular story
he basically stumbled across a military
base and the arrival of The Incredible
Hulk
came to the attention of Zin knew who in
turn began developing or basically
recreating all these different monsters
of superior strengths that had existed
and used them to try to take down the
Incredible Hulk so we don't really know
about the other three just because there
are things like goons stuff like that
it's weird like they're like blood
monsters and like lava monsters and so
on and so well they're kind of pokey and
a little bit silly but Groot as he's
depicted here was basically recreated
now the funny thing about this is
remember this is not the grief that you
know needs you know in terms of its
strengths but in terms of his power and
so on and so forth he's still very much
similar in the things he's just a giant
tree but the idea here is that he speaks
in clear and concise sentences and again
this was really just part of the whole
you know Dan Abnett slash Brian Michael
Bendis slash Marvel redoing their whole
cosmology thing when they brought
through that and all he did was just say
I am Groot I mean that was kind of a
level
the nature of them and of course that
led into its own line of stories in
terms of what it is that groots really
saying but the idea here is it seeing
him and The Incredible Hulk fight one
another is actually pretty wildly just
keep in mind Groot is wildly strong in
terms of where he stands but the
Incredible Hulk has limitless strength
and again at this point it wasn't really
like the upper echelon of the Hulk
strength but what we saw in all my
videos you know by Greg Pak would be
incredible hope where it was like
wallbreaker Hulk and I part of the
monster Haul where he's just got like
the power of gods and he could take down
some of the higher you know some those
powerful beings in existence release
some of those powerful physical beings
in existence you could really punch
eternity I doubt but the fact remains
here that um with him going against
Groot it's very much it's kind of an
exchange it's pretty straightforward and
that's what these companies were these
coming for this really straightforward
things there wasn't a lot to go into
there wasn't a lot of discussion it was
just group trying to wreck him but the
funny thing about this is that at the
time when Groot was written here because
he was a floor colossi meaning he was
basically just a giant tree he would
route himself into the ground and what
it would do is it would make him almost
impossible to stop you really just
couldn't move him I mean once his brutes
were embedded down into the ground it
was almost impossible to make him go
anywhere and that's kind of what happens
back and forth between these two now of
course the Incredible Hulk had never
fought group before and so because of
that the hooks actually kind of tried to
figure out what in the world is going on
because remember from the hooks
perspective when somebody gets in his
way they get smashed and the hope goes
on it's one of the three core rules of
the universe right like like the
Cleveland Browns will never go to the
Superbowl your girlfriend or wife is
always right and the Incredible Hulk
basically crushes everything that he
goes against but when he's facing off
against Groot because the fact that
Groot is rooted into the ground it's
almost impossible to the to stop
them now the other half of this is Groot
uses things you know like these
invincible thorns or things like that
remember his powers are very much rooted
in terms of tree based aspects now this
wasn't really taken to account what
things we would see later on when the
role of Groot is expanded in Marvel
Comics and he's basically able to like
ensnare people and extend his own limbs
whatever things like that it doesn't
really work that way right now he's just
a really really strong tree more or less
but ultimately once Hawk realizes that
the basis behind groups near
indestructibility is the fact that he is
rooted into the ground The Incredible
Hulk in turn just smashes the ground
upwards Groot and then just Wrexham and
really yet I mean he just he just tears
on the pieces just like smashing my
heart with rocks and that's pretty much
the end of him I mean we're just
basically vanishes now the funny thing
about this is that this would be the
portrayal of group going forward for a
lot of stories in Marvel Comics he would
table up every once in a while and I
mean like once in a blue moon he would
appear because he's one of those
characters that Marvel always wanted to
kind of keep on the back burner not
really to keep fans relevant you know
keep fans interested in him they keep
them on the back burner somebody for
copyright purposes because remember
whenever it comes to characters or
something like that you know if a
character is created and they laughs for
any real measure of time like decades
then it can ultimately lead to them you
know potentially losing that character
now I can't imagine why DC would
basically try to claim root for their
own I have a hard time imagining what a
story would look like with Superman
versus root I would read it but I have a
hard time imagining what that story
would look like it would be awesome yeah
I would love to see that like a Green
Lantern group could you imagine that
like grid gets like the Green Lantern
Lantern it would be a Mickey City it
would be an awesome story but the fact
remains here that that would route as
you know him again when Dan Abbot was
kind of going through that and because
the story is so sure I think we can
afford to kind of have this little bit
of an explanation here but because of
the fact that you know Dan Abnett most
guys would basically go up to the
entirety of the Marvel cosmology and
then turn around and made it cohesive
and expanded on it which again will
cover all that cosmic stuff next year a
group we basically just kind of rolled
into the fold and for the most part this
version of route was just kind of long
and forgotten they basically just sort
of ignored and just kind of left him
behind
which made sense because nobody really
had a reason to sit down you know while
they were reading anihilation is like
but wait a minute
what happened in that version of route
who was like really eloquent and talked
well and was fighting the Hulk and Hulk
annual number number five I mean nobody
really had a reason to ask that question
especially when the guardians of the
galaxy movie came out people just wanted
to see like the group that they were
familiar with in the film which you know
of course you find in modern-day
guardians of the galaxy stories but any
of them guys just kind of want to throw
this out there just kind of have this
little bit of a video you know we were
talking about be Incredible Hulk
fighting Groot it's a cool little moment
it's a cool little segment just to kind
of see the TV all head-to-head and truth
I wouldn't be surprised if later on down
the line we saw a tried and true story
with like a modern-day Bruce Banner
going against a modern-day Groot I think
that sort of be a more identifiable and
more relatable to people who are out
there looking to see a story like that I
think maybe a little more grounded maybe
I'll be able to get a little more
investment into it but any of them guys
if you are new here to come in to
explain make sure you hit the sub button
to become part of the Rob port if you
guys enjoyed this video make sure you
drop a like and yeah I will catch you
all later peace
[Music]
you